good morning good morning I see there
are already some people waiting and some
questions that I will get to and even
some speculation because Eric hadn't
heard from me that you know maybe that
I'd be late not late
but you know I got a number of things
that I do in the morning and and then I
finally get around to Eric sends me a
link so that I can follow this on my
iPad where I can see the questions at
any rate today I want before I get to
your questions I want to talk about
something that comes up you know how
many words can you learn so I said you
can learn 100 word today
so as often happens when I say something
like that and sometimes I say it to be a
little provocative although a tintype is
true then I often get a lot of pushback
no or you can learn them but then you
forget them and stuff like that or what
do you mean by no a word and so on so
before I get into showing you why you
know how so I've said because our
statistics that lake really better track
how many words you know you add to your
known word total every month I can see
that in my statistics and I'm gonna show
you that so I can talk about how many
words you can learn in a month and this
is quite important because learning a
language is essentially about acquiring
words all right so if I look at my
Arabic for a Persian I kind of have a
sense of how the grammar works now there
are some issues in Arabic is subjunctive
and sometimes it's used and sometimes it
isn't than in any case most people don't
speak for side streets and so there's
lots a fine point but I've got 80 90
percent of the grammar
I can't necessarily produce it but I
understand how the language worked the
same is true with Persian I kind of
understand how it works they also have a
subjunctive and they have you know they
have different things they have a future
when it's written and they don't use the
future when they speak
and you know there's some sometimes
different forms of the word depending on
the spoken language versus the written
language so there are all these things
that you kind of have a sense of however
if I go to read something if I go to
read an article from al Jazeera the
biggest obstacle I have is that I don't
know the words if I knew you know and so
let's say there's 30% new or unknown
words there or 40% that makes it very
difficult to work your way through them
it used to be 60% so I am moving towards
you know fewer and fewer unknown words
and I see that because if I open a
lesson there's more white and white
means that it's a known word so then the
question is so what do you mean when you
know a word people say you know well I
say the way we measure it link is that
when you read something if you don't
look the word up you know it all right
now you may find that the next time you
see that word in a different context
you don't know it which is fine and then
you might say it again and this is just
the statistics I just but the basic
principle is that we are learning from
content
what matters is can you make can we
derive meaning from this content so if
we are missing words we don't know what
they mean we have to look them up so
typically on a link lesson page you have
blue words those are words that you have
not seen before but you may already know
those words but you haven't seen them
before at link so they're Malou so
therefore if you don't save that word if
you don't create a link as we call it
will you pass over that word then the
assumption is you know that word that's
what the system says you do not know
that word if you don't know the word and
you look it up it's now yellow and over
time that yellow word can move to B K it
begins as a status one word and then
when it becomes a status for word
it's known and it can move to know in a
variety of ways and I have to admit that
I don't know all of the the ways in
which
this happens but it's primarily when you
review them and when you review them
more than a certain number of times and
you get it right or whatever then it
moves to known automatically or and this
is most often case with me I will move
them to known manually like I'll say
okay this this is a word I've seen
before I try to have sort of think I
know what it means but I'm not confident
I can figure it out from this context
but really I'm not confident of this
word so I might move it from status 1 to
status to order status 3 and then I
might move it to status for or status
for means that it'll still reappear on
my space repetition thing but if I move
it to the tick now won't ever see it
again and so I move these up manually
all right now how many words can you
learn in a month so I'm gonna show you
my statistics but the interesting thing
is that most of the words we learn we
are not aware that we're learning them
the the number of words that I learned
as a result of having created a link and
reviewed the word and moved it up
manually in most languages is small
whereas the words that you acquire
naturally over time is much greater and
this is because if you're an English
native speaker of English and you're
learning French or Spanish half of the
vocabulary in French or Spanish is more
or less recognizable to you and once you
get the hang of how it changes into
French or Spanish priests who you aren't
saving those words because you know what
they mean or once you figured out
something about common education that I
can give achieve I avow those are three
different words forms of the verb but
they're the same verb so after a while
you don't say that any longer so that in
this way if you were learning languages
that are in some way familiar similar to
languages that you know you acquire
vocabulary very quickly on the other
hand as I
demonstrate in my statistics when I
study languages like Arabic Persian
Greek it takes a lot longer and so you
cannot acquire a hundred words a day but
even in the Slavic languages there's a
lot of different forms with the same
word you start you know for example
hearing learning Chinese and once you
have acquired a certain number of
characters and you start to see these
characters reappear in combination with
other characters that you may know then
you have a sense of what that word means
that like if you have for those of you
who know Chinese if you have you know
Hugh gade gade ya guys Shia and you know
those characters you get a sense of what
the word means so you may you may save
it once just to confirm the meaning but
very quickly you'll move it to non
because that's easy to remember
similarly I mentioned this idea of
cognates or what's sometimes called
false friends they may have a slightly
different meaning in another language
but they're easy to remember so there
are a lot of freebies most words are
acquired incidentally so before I then
get to questions I just want to give you
a brief demonstration of how this works
using our statistics link so let me just
share my screen
no I gotta this is my Twitter feed let
us go to link here okay so I just
looking I was looking at different
languages and I presume that everyone
can see this but I was looking at
different languages and so if I take
Polish as an exam well no yeah we do
polish so polish was sort of my hmm
third Slavic language fourth maybe after
Ukrainian so I kinda I this is looking
at polish all time
so I started poking a bit learned a
little bit of Polish didn't do much and
then in
basically the summer of 2015 or the
latter half of 2015 I guess a must-have
Donna a 90 day challenge and I went at
polished health and in one month I
learned 9594 words that is to say my non
words total in polish increased by nine
thousand five hundred words so you know
each month was three thousand words each
month so that's a lot of words now
that's because I knew russian-ukrainian
check so let's look at the case of now
Russia was the first language I did hear
a link so you'll see that I went I say
the struggled struggled struggled and
this is often the case when you're in a
language I'm in that situation right now
with my Arabic and Persian but as you
start to get a hang of the language
different forms of the same word better
understanding of the context all of a
sudden you can start adding a lot of
words to your neural code you can also
read more and read more new stuff like
I'm still in this situation in Arabic
and Persian when I'm rereading a lot of
the old stuff because I still can't
remember the words and I still can't
fully understand it when I hear it but
once I get better at the language then I
can go and read more and more new stuff
and at that point I'll be adding I mean
maybe not 4,000 words a month but a lot
of words to my non-work tour because
here in Russian here I'm dealing with a
different writing system the Cyrillic
writing system and I'm dealing with a
brand new language family which has
fewer words from other European
languages it does have some I don't know
what the percentage is but that would
not account for this these spikes in my
monthly you know I increase in no Lord :
this is because I am able to read more
read more new material more familiar
with the context more familiar with how
the language works so that was Russia if
I look ok
let's see another interesting example is
Romania I really only studied Romanian
for a few months because I was going to
Romania I mean I haven't done anything
on Romanian since but within a couple of
months I got up to $20,000 words and the
reason for that is that in Romanian 70%
of the vocabulary is easily identifiable
from Italian 20% is identifiable from
Slavic languages and there's another 10%
which is the original you know whatever
was there before the influence of these
other languages so in a case of very
similar languages like a Spanish speaker
who goes to study Portuguese or
vice-versa they can add no thousands of
words then if I bring all the words they
know all the words in the other language
so if we're just talking about the issue
of non words now if I they may not
understand it when they hear it but they
certainly have all the words so if I go
now - let's see yeah check again it's
gonna be very similar I went through a
period of you know very heavy
involvement with check and so in some of
those months and again check came after
Russian so I already had a lot of the
Slavic Gaby Larry like fifty sixty
percent of the words are recognizable so
I went pretty quickly but if I go now or
even so Greek is very Greek you know my
peak month I only had 328 words because
again there's very few common work or
just a different writing system there's
some issues in the Greek spelling or a
lot of you know sounds can be written in
three or four different I would say a
lot but some it's a bizarre it was
tougher and the other problem in in
Greek was trying to find hottest no
other issue is to to try to find that
intermediate content I had to go from
basically the mini story is straight to
a podcast that I had transcribed with
it's very difficult
and so these are things that influence
how many words you can learn in a month
so here I peaked at 328 is that what it
says at 3,000 sorry 900 where I'm up to
8,000 so that's actually novel that's
not true I did when I went at it very
heavily later on I was able to heat oh
no that's not baby that's a month three
thousand two hundred eighty two words
and that's wrong in our statistical so
there yeah so again you'll see you pick
up speed as you as you progress in the
language you get more familiar with the
language you can have a really and this
was just prior to my going to Crete then
I made a particular focus and I got up
to 3,000 words not daily monthly that's
so if I now go to Persian so you'll see
there that I peaked here because I sort
of played around with it a bit then I
dropped it in preparation for going to
Morocco where I focused instead on on
Arabic and now I have been working
harder at it so this keeps on saying
decade that's not correct its monthly
four hundred sixty five hundred eighty
six now so I'm getting let's say five
hundred a month of Persian that is added
to my known words total and that's
bearing in mind that I cannot that I
spending a lot of time going over
already familiar material I'm not yet at
a stage bragging forge ahead into
enjoyable new material all the time
because when you start doing that you
can really pump up your knowledge total
but you can see here that I went at
Arabic fairly heavily he got it up to
say nine hundred a month and then of
course this then dropped off I guess we
were traveling because I did a lot of
traveling then I bumped it up prior to
going to Morocco and
then yeah I find Arabic more difficult
than Persian so I'm doing a lot of
reviewing of existing material to get a
better sense of the language so I'm
adding three hundred and some words new
words two main elements total together
with the whatever it was five six
hundred of Persian so it's about a
thousand a month so I guess in
conclusion nah let's stop this so in
conclusion you know I think the number
of known words that you can add to your
own words coral is going to vary from I
mean even in difficult languages like
Persian and Arabic and I'm doing both of
them and that's slowing me down like
artists I'm today as a transition day I
go from arabic to persian but i was just
starting to get into some actually i'm
going through I see Neil again I'm
enjoying the Persian I said no more the
second time or not um over the third
time around and but I don't have to lay
the book down and go into Persian so
that slows me down because I want to get
forward to that stage where and start
really
I don't enjoy reading the articles from
al-jazeera because are promised bad cut
which I have transcribed because they're
still too difficult but if they were
just a little bit easier I would move
more quickly and I would acquire more
new know words
but anyway 1000 to 10,000 that's the
range of what you can achieve in a month
in my opinion on a program of you know
really you know focusing in on listening
and reading and I do very little
deliberate you know memorizing
flashcards I do it on a random basis
occasionally but I don't it's not a big
part of my learning strategy now before
I answer your questions a couple of
comments here people say well you know
how do you know if you know a word stop
it's passive knowledge of the word I
believe that passive vocabulary is very
important because in most situations
comprehension is more important than
what you are able to say if I watch a
movie if I'm reading a book if I'm
listening to a podcast
what matters is what can I understand
and if I understand a lot it's a bit
like a snowball if I don't understand
much
then the range of things that I can
listen to read whatever is limited the
more I understand the richer I get the
rich get richer the poor get blurred the
more words I have the more interesting
things that I can explore the more
vocabulary I'm gonna get so the passive
vocabulary is tremendously important and
I don't worry so much about what I can
say now I worry about what I will be
able to say a year from now and in order
to be and I want to be in meaningful
conversations because then I'm gonna get
vocabulary from the native speaker who
will be using native speaker will always
have a much broader work a better than I
have and I'm gonna be able to you know
acquire those words if I can hold up my
end of the conversation in order to hold
up my end of the conversation I have to
understand what they're saying so
passive vocabulary is very important now
when do these words convert into active
vocabulary what can we do that's another
discussion I don't think we're aware
sometimes when these words convert and
there are strategies that can help you
convert them into active words but you
know we can't measure that at length and
I think that the easiest thing to
measure and the best measure of your
potential in a language is you the size
of your passive vocabulary that's where
we measure that link and without wanting
to brag about it if you have 90,000
words in Russian that might be
equivalent to 30,000 words in English
because there's so many more different
forms of words in Russian it doesn't
matter I'm not I'm not in the Olympics
I'm not trying to brag about this but
it's it's sort of it's a motivator it's
tough these are milestones I know that
I'm at 7500 words in Arabic and 2,000
words in Persian when I get to 15,000
words in Arabic I'm gonna be taking off
when I get to 10,000 words in Persian
I'm gonna be taking off so I'm very much
motivated to increase my known words
total which is my passive were
vocabulary at link and I think that we
pick up speed as we
and to get from 1,000 to 2,000 to 3,000
words a month is not difficult okay now
let us see what we have okay go right
back to the ene can you talk some more
about the boat trip you took to get to
France when you first went to believe it
was when you were working with people
okay so here's a question so it's not
related to today's subject but so I
decided in Montreal to go down to the
dock and I wanted the hitchhike to
Europe and so for three days I went on
two ships
I said hello can I speak to the captain
and they said fine I mean it just shows
you how much the world's changed I mean
today I would have been arrested ever
suspected of being a terrorist there's
nothing but notice they just said fine
in most cases I got to be to see the
captain I said look I'm prepared to work
for free I want to get across the Europe
have you got any you know job for me
that I can do and on the third day the
captain of this small German ship said
yes and so I went across and the crew
was half German half Spanish and so we
all have stereotypes and the stereotype
is his Spanish speakers are all you know
fast whatever have a good time and the
Germans aren't working whereas on this
trip all of the Spanish they were from
Galicia and my lot of fun they were and
they were hard working in the Germans
couldn't wait until dinner time and they
would you know consume doesn't be here
before they passed over so that was kind
of interesting it was a very smaller
sort of ship bla bla bla bla bla
mmm
say a little bit about language learning
at age age is not a factor you know you
have to use your brain you have to use
your brain and if you use your brain you
create new neural connections it doesn't
matter what age you are
since the so in I guess that was 60 or
58 or whatever I wrote my book and at
that time I spoke nine languages and I'm
now working on language 19 and 20
okay I'm 73 so that's 13 years since the
age of 60 yesterday my wife and I played
golf with a neurologist from Nashville
Tennessee him and his son
very nice a couple of guys and we talked
a bit and I said oh yeah neurology so I
can't resist relating everything back to
language learning and I said I read a
book once written by a German you know
cognitive scientist neurologist who said
to learn anything
we need repetition but we need novelty
and this gets back to in language
learning we can't just go over the same
stuff all the time we get this year of
diminishing returns we have to go and
find new stuff and I've talked about
interleaving learning and coming back
and he said yes he says if you don't do
anything new you aren't creating new
neural circuits in the brain you have to
create these and we can create these at
any age research has shown that that
brain remain plastic so that it's all a
matter of motivation and initially it's
tough you have to force you have to
force this a you know these new networks
to be created in your brain not a factor
of age well I hope to learn more and in
a salon blah thank you for inspiration I
also enjoy listening to your audiobook
the linguist book has helped get into
listening something I really didn't do a
lot of okay yeah I know this thing is so
key listening is so key it's the it's
the core listening is the core you
listen you don't understand you want to
get into it listening is so portable you
can do it anywhere but it's not just
listening for background noise it to me
it's listening that's why I like it I
get on our playlist and then if I if I'm
listening and I might as I said the
other day random scramble the playlist
then I hear something that I don't
really understand so I go and look at my
iPad
what playlist on my listening to right
now I can click on it and get to the
lesson I can read it again listening
triggers a lot of our learning
bah-bah-bah listen to it there is
however one thing that has been on my
mind where the girls you talk to in
grenoble impress fix it is a long time
ago I mean once you can communicate with
people
however porty you just become a part of
the group I didn't ask them if they were
impressed if there were I was with a
bunch of Swedish people they were all
speaking Swedish and I was chiming in
with however limited my Swedish was I
was just part of their group I don't
remember
okay I'm reading Rich Dad Poor Dad and
there's a lot of words that are female
and offering notes the more about
financial stuff and approaching myself
cuz I don't know meaning well Matteo's I
would say I would advise you to buy the
e-book and import it in a link and then
save those words and expressions and get
to know them if that's that kind of you
know that terminology is important to
you then you should focus on and do a
lot of reading and don't just read the
one book read that book and read another
book and read a variety of different
things that relate to financial stuff or
if you don't get the the ebook for that
book it's a financial terminology and
then go find out
it goes on the internet and import them
into link I find beginner content pretty
boring but I don't know enough to read
or listen stuff of interest should I
stick to beginner stuff or what you kind
of have to do a bit of both
this is Nicholas you have to kind of do
a bit of both
you know obviously we need to hit
starting with the beginner stuff but
then we explore some of the more
difficult stuff it's too difficult we
beat back we go back into the beginner
stuff and that's what I was saying once
you reach a stage where you're more
comfortable and
more interesting stuff then your no
words total is going to increase very
very quickly because you're able to
actually understand it and move along
but that's something you have to explore
for your self what your threshold of you
know for pain is because it is more
difficult and it's a bit of a struggle
to read the more difficult stuff and yet
it's boring to read the simple stuff so
you have to figure out your own strategy
I'm a native English speaker I had
registered and I have to look at words
okay I find it much better to read for
fun and information when learning a
language like the links on website but I
don't study them just look yeah that's
right that's how you that's how you
progress how can we learn the spoken
language not only language in this
papers anymore formal writing to me you
know the language you get out of
newspapers out of books it's the base
it's the base you need that the spoken
language is not so different unless you
just want to say hi how are ya you know
how's it going that's very easy other
than that you're gonna be talking about
some subject of substance and they're
the vocabulary essentially the same as
what you're reading however what you can
do is if you find your favorite TV show
on YouTube and it has subtitles you can
import that interlink as a lesson and
study the vocabulary and in that way
you'll be picking out more of the sort
of conversational language but I don't
think the conversational language is so
difficult to acquire how can you learn
it's going okay any tips on what
Japanese books we should start reading
when aresia
I'm sorry I'm not doing Japanese maybe
Eric has some suggestions I simply have
no idea what would be a good next level
book in Japanese what to do to not get
rusty in certain languages well I'm
refreshed them i refresh them at link if
I know I'm gonna need a certain language
if I'm you know if I'm sometimes I used
to get invited on television in
Vancouver to speak you know in Mandarin
on panel discussion or something and I
spend an hour or so and certainly on my
way to the radio or television studio
I would be listening to my Mandarin CDs
okay yeah I wouldn't worry too much
about manda panda about pronunciation
rules if you listen a lot you naturally
get a sense of how the language is
pronounced you may occasionally review
the pronunciation rules I wouldn't try
to remember them I would focus more on
my ability to notice what I hear but
occasionally you can read the I'm using
a book dedicated to pronunciation well I
think pronunciation is not something
that we control through reading books
reading a book with some rules on
pronunciation may point some things out
to you that you hadn't noticed but
mostly you just have to listen a lot I
met a guy in Vancouver actually who
spoke phenomenal English he was from
China and I said what did what did you
do how can you speak so well you sound
almost like a Chinese Canadian to me I
mean he looks Chinese he speaks English
almost like a Canadian he said I had
this one CD and I listened to it a
thousand times no that's what he said
I'm not sure I could do that but he said
that's the secret to his pronunciation
Chinese characters I think you know do
you think writing them interfacing is
the best way well initially you may need
to trace them although most resources
that teach Chinese characters will give
you stroke order so you simply have to
get used to that stroke order I found
that I had to write them out the first
thousand and and even thereafter because
when I was doing Chinese we had to write
translate we have to write essays in
Chinese I found that writing was
important for me to be able to recognize
is that necessary I don't know
I read
you know Korean I have never written
Korean by hand I have never written
Cyrillic by hand I have never written
grief by hand I've never had a big
script by hand and I managed fine but
when I did the Chinese I wrote the plan
okay if you're not having fun don't do
it fine and curiosity you may say your
brain is secrete all right
neurotransmitters cannulas or I know
that I may email him about Hungarian
translations can you also email me Steve
Abid link because then I have your email
address and maybe we've already been in
communication sometimes don't know if
I'm speaking to the same person or not
send me another email I will follow up
with zora and he has a lot of stuff to
do and I will follow up with him well
would you check out my usually whatever
what video just see the Fiona Sao video
much young fellow glad to hear it
Scott that's all fuzzy but there are one
maybe two nerves responsible for memory
living downtown basically whatever
when you go on vacation you take a break
from studying or do use the opportunity
to try out a new language well I mean if
I'm in Latin America and we were with
another couple the only language
activity is speaking to the taxi drivers
in Spanish or Portuguese didn't really
spend much time on any formal form of
language training okay there's one if
you have four years to learn to like
there is one for pleasure one for
business after four years in what order
do you go about learning them well I
would do now I would go 80% on the one
for business and then as a treat we
would allow myself 20 percent of the
time to do the one that I am more
motivated to learn
okay all irises of his listening is a
male assistant to be Nando I'm not sure
I know a meaning of the word to be none
law in Doyle and amazes mo listening is
dr. banana the list I mean listening
takes a while to develop if that's the
point it takes a while to develop you
can read and understand and yet when we
listen to in trouble you just have to
keep listening but say thank you
continue Nora oh we'll do you get more
known words or the flash gardener
reading through previous lessons reading
reading I mean in other words do I
convert more save links to known through
flash Carling or through reading far
more through reading when I'm reading
and I see a word that I'm comfortable
now I move it to know ah any tips about
Russian vocabulary lots of listening and
reading that's the only tip forget Steve
Aaron yes it doesn't like flash are you
in front of them because they present
the word okay that's fine I hope you are
doing fine what do you think about
Russian land
I love the Russian language to be fair I
love every night news that I'm learning
I really love the Arabic language I love
the person language and I particularly
like the fact that it's a lot easier
than Arabic Russian is difficult in the
sense that there's a lot of tricky sort
of grammar things I love the sound of
the language and I love the fact that
I'm able to understand it when I hear it
it gives me a tremendous sense of
satisfaction and that satisfaction that
you know I can access this world that
was you know that that I had very little
understanding of before but that's the
case with all the languages that I
learned do I think you're Allan Poe
stories are difficult to read noticed
and
an English Learner I don't know oh I'm a
fan of 19th century literature in French
in Russia I've used in Spanish even in
Italian I don't find those particularly
difficult but I have no idea how an
English language learner would find it
Allen Poe okay how would you approach
learning Japanese after learning
hiragana katakana well I think I think
you should learn to come to you because
if you're gonna read you're gonna come
across kanji so kanji is a major major
task it's not difficult per se but it's
very time-consuming and I think is
something one should get on as early as
possible and it's just one of the hosts
thing you know when I studied Chinese
there was this law some p.m. for anybody
who's familiar with Chinese Maoist
propaganda there were the Lao Soompi and
the three famous essay is one of which
was you go i shun the foolish old man
who moved the mountain and the idea
there was this man was digging away this
mountain and everybody said it was a
fool and said yeah but I'll continue
digging and my son will continue to
continue digging and his son after him
so learning characters is a bit like
that it's a tremendous task and you just
have to get at it and do it every day
and gradually you'll learn them please
make a bit about changing tones of
Chinese okay sir glad so I jumped a bit
the alphabet in Russian of all the
things in Russian that are difficult the
alphabet is not one of them yes it's
strange yes you will never read us
comfortably in any new alphabet as you
read in the one that you have been
reading since childhood but if you
compare that to learning Chinese
characters Arabic hun-gu let's it's not
so difficult just get at it you're gonna
continue to confuse you know the P and
the R and all this kind of stuff but you
just have to keep reading and list and
keep reading keep reading and eventually
you just get better you don't get worse
changing tones of Chinese okay to me the
tones in Chinese is a problem it's
difficult it's one of the difficulties
in Chinese in many ways Chinese is an
easy language to learn but the
characters and the tones make it
difficult you can try to you should be
aware of officially what the tone is one
two three four ma ma ma but you're gonna
get a better feel for them if you learn
the if you don't phrases if you learn
phrases safe phrases hear the phrases
yah yah yah yah yah yah cute so and
there are things in the tones that
sometimes they you know we have a boo
you know it can change if it's in a
phrase so you kind of get these phrases
in your head and it starts to come out
naturally one of the things I did was I
listened to a lot of Zhong Xiang Xiang
are these Chinese economic dialogues
where they exaggerated the tones so if
you listen to these calming dialogues it
tends to again exaggerate the music of
the language and that's what you have to
do with the tones darkness
yeah ash before
yeah so if your listening comprehension
is five to ten percent you just gotta
keep listening listen don't understand
read look up the words review the words
listen again and and and again this
whole idea about creating new networks
so listen to stuff that's old and try to
get a little bit more each time but also
push the envelope a little bit
by listening the new stuff keeps things
fresh in the brain then go back to the
old stuff the area and eventually you
will improve okay could you give me some
advice even if I don't understand you
think I should keep watching your video
so you know so you know if there are if
there are closed captions which I
believe there are two these videos which
I'm curry and I want to be good at
English that is why I subscribe use but
I'm not good at licking if I can't
understand what you say perfectly okay
first of all don't expect to understand
it perfectly that comes much much later
okay I have put a lot of effort in the
learning Korean I don't understand I
mean my comprehend depending on the
content 30 40
sixty percent I want to get from thirty
to forty forty to fifty gradually
improved it's a long road if the brain
learns the brain cannot do otherwise
then learn the brain is a learning
machine but the brain learns slowly okay
so you have to be patient but you have
to recognize that the brain will always
learn all the stimulus is coming out it
is forcing the brain to rearrange I mean
I'm not a neuroscientist but the brain
works but you have to you have to keep
feeding the brain stimulating the brain
and it will learn but it learns slowly
so your ability to understand will
improve slowly if there are subtitles to
this video then you should import that
interlink and go over all the words
because I talk about language learning
all the time
so at the very least if you did all my
videos you would have good vocabulary on
that side okay and but you can do that
with other thing you can do that with
television programs and so forth so
writing and tracing times before trying
to memorize them first no no first of
all I do not try to memorize necessarily
anything I just found that with Chinese
characters I would I had these
flashcards about actual physical cards
and I would look at one and I would
write it up ten times on a piece of
paper okay but it was squared paper and
then I would stop and I would pick up
the second one and I would write it out
and it was squared papers that that
meant that there were columns and so I
would put the meaning or the
pronunciation like if it's I walk I
would put wo walk with sound the tone
sign over on the third call and then I
pick up another one I keep doing that
and then I run into the wall in a few
minutes so then I gotta write it again
and then I move it forward so it was my
before I even heard of the term spaced
repetition I had my own primitive spaced
repetition system and I just did that
and so I did started ten a day took it
up to thirty a day and I would always
shuffle old ones in there because I knew
whatever I learned yesterday I was going
forget half of it or more but so it was
not so much a deliberate memorization
strategy as an exposure strategy if you
feed the brain enough stimulus exposure
the brain will eventually learn I don't
try to memorize I don't test myself I
just go through it one of the best
Chinese resources I have no idea I'm no
longer doing Chinese mm-hmm
is it worth when you're listening to a
video and YouTube you change the normal
speed and put it faster or should I
listen in the now area I don't see any
benefit in moving it to faster do you
think languages can help you socialize
with people more sure you all of a
sudden you can talk to people that don't
speak your language so that's got a you
know in that you can access more people
expand your social context don't curse
thing okay here's none of this PewDiePie
have no idea what PewDiePie is I have
zero interest in PewDiePie and I hope
people will stop talking about PewDiePie
Peter what do you think people just
nothing when you speak their language
why do I come across do you use music as
a method to learn no I presume you mean
songs songs with words but I don't use
songs mmm uh Steve you inspire me I've
been following your child for two years
I speak magenta thanks Robby thank you
and blah blah blah mother tongue is
Arabic I've been learning Persian for
years by the time I was 8 - or b1 I
myself often understanding how Fez more
than my Persian friends can you believe
that you know the Persian and Erik are
two completely different language facts
Persian is an indo-european language
obviously Arabic is Semitic language
like our mayekar Hebrew but there are
30% or so Arabic words in Persian and I
find it really helps
and I'm very glad that I'm doing them
both at the same time although sometimes
I wish I could stay on the one
longer do you think memorizing phrases
will boost the speed of learning as I
said before I don't deliberately
memorize anything I exposed myself to
content and I exposed myself to you know
if I save a bunch of phrases in link and
then I tagged them for example for you
know case endings in Russian then I will
review those phrases so I will give
myself concentrated exposure
concentrated examples of a certain
pattern in the length but it's always
exposure it's not a deliberate attempt
to memorize steve is a Latin language
Zen master I'm not a master but I'll
tell you that there is a lot in Zen or
in the towers Chinese you know drums a
Taoist philosophy that really relates to
language money it's seeing it's
imitating it's not pushing it too hard
it's doing the things that sometimes
things that you know are enjoyable that
you can continue doing it's all of that
kind of a fuzzy thing it's not
deliberate memorization in Japanese
property you have to know how to write
the characters I would to me characters
country is part of learning Japanese if
all you want to do is go to the bar and
drink beer and chat people up then you
don't need the characters but if you
want to learn the language I believe you
know you need the characters : 10 I want
to if they don't button that lets go
something listen or this is Louis you
know how do you maintain motivation if
people aren't interested in your success
you don't learn language for other
people you learn a language for yourself
yung-chun know this young song is not
fragrant Mountain Yong Chun is Yong Chun
is mutual sound young Chun
alright the way I study Japanese
imparted to five plus one thread psyche
thank you a lot
okay fragrant mountain no that's young
sure and there we go
is afraid of constancy don't boo boo
haunted I'll see seek no I don't think
that Lane learning languages makes you
narcissistic
just like at our church what's your
thought on reading books and listening
to audiobooks do they feel the same to
you you know if if I'm say in if I if I
have dedicated time I'm gonna read I
enjoyed reading I enjoy reading cuz I
can go at my own speed I can imagine
what I'm reading I can stop her I want I
like reading the advantage of listening
is that I can do it in the car I can do
it while exercising I can do it in so
many different places I would not sit
down and listen say to an audiobook but
I can recollect cross-country skiing for
hours listening to you know Russian
novels Italian novels whatever it's
different it's a different experience
it's part of the same in a sense it's
the same because you know writing was
invented before the mp3 player both our
ways you know audio recording writing
are simply ways of recording what people
say now prior to that you had to rely on
storytellers they're both good and I
think some people may prefer the one or
the other
I find that listening tends to you know
I don't know where it goes in the brain
but it tends to prepare you better for
speaking whereas reading is better for
acquiring vocabulary but I do both and
now I have to write them by hand improve
it soprano Sam I got better watch
cameras at least writing wise I don't
raise speak yeah but if you had an
opportunity to speak have you heard
about the silent way isn't a Pacific
what do you think okay so there are
there's a fellow in Thailand who has a
program for learning Thai and he is
adamant that no one should speak Thai
you know until they've gone through six
months or something like he forbids his
people to speak I am against any sort of
you know prohibition of speaking if I
were in Thailand learning Thai from
scratch
from day one I'd be out there trying out
whenever I could that's that's what I
would be motivated to do why would I you
know deny myself the pleasure of trying
out a few words that I've learned on the
other hand all if I'm say in Vancouver
learning Thai I would not be pushing
myself to speak to someone because I
think the time that I spend listening
and reading is going to bring me better
bett more benefits but now that I have
enough Persian when I get back to
Vancouver and I run into Persian
shopkeepers or clerks and department
stores and there are lots of them
you can bet I'm going to use whatever
Persian I have is linked comprehensive
enough to be my only matter and learning
tool I'm still at a very early early
level okay I you know I've said it
before whatever we learn if we can learn
it using different content different
forms so we listen we read we grab a
book we count the same it - I'd like to
buy two different starter box teach
yourself colloquial so I would not rely
on one system alone link has a big
advantage with like to me it's very
unfortunate that these starter books
like teach yourself or a CML don't make
their material available in digital
format so that it can be imported into
link and that we can study them we can
look at words and we can use all of the
benefits of the link system in
combination with these text books and so
then like I'm doing right now with ICML
which I have imported into link I
sometimes do it on my iPad and sometimes
I grab the book so I would not limit
myself I think it's good for the brain
again to have her you know different
approaches different forms this kind of
thing maybe it's good to learn through
songs I'm gonna try this good go for it
yeah what is have you ever tried Irish
or any Celtic language no so
mundo mark feels that he's not learning
even though he's studying much again if
you're if you're studying that's
best way if you are engaging with the
language if you are enjoying the
language you're listening you're reading
you're speaking to people all of these
things that you're doing with the
language you are necessarily improving
okay so and if you're enjoying what
you're doing you will improve if you are
deliberately studying going over the
same grammar explanations doing the same
exercises yes you will gradually achieve
less and less and less so give yourself
some new exposure to the language go
find some new content do things that are
different and that'll stimulate new
activity in the brain thank you for
answering my question I'll tell my
Korean friend musti's ja now my friend
will subscribe to your channel with me
you're a nice guy well thank you and
maybe you know I'm actually planning to
get back to Korean in the second half of
the year because I'm going to the
polyglot conference in Japan and Fukuoka
in October I think there will be people
there from Korea yeah and it's just a
good excuse to get my Korean to a higher
level which means I will Park my Arabic
and Persian and focus in on well first
of all I park my Arabic and Persian
because I'm gonna go to Ukraine so I
gotta get my slobbing languages back and
then I'm gonna go to Korean so maybe we
can chat in Korean Monday trotty her cos
no no get me Dada don't understand but
maybe one day some research suggests
that listen to audio books and reading
books are pretty much identical
activities for his brain activity is
concerned as long as you don't lose
concentration that could well be I don't
know looks do you have a Chinese name
yeah I do is go like Gauss's gauze and
go sir
sister julienne de su casa su I've been
learning five languages Chinese Irish
Greek Arabic and Japanese from her
sometime you know with no Russian master
named for managing this many different
languages no I can't imagine doing that
I'm having trouble going back and forth
between Persian and Arabic where there's
some mutual sort of reinforcement the
on the vocabularies I I don't know what
to say I hope it works for you ah if a
person that has both parents that speak
European language was born in Chinese
know what he learns Chinese slower than
his Chinese peers having the same
linguistic environment as them probably
like no different than a Chinese
immigrant to an english-speaking country
who speaks Chinese at home and then
learns English from his peers one thing
to remember the influence of the peers
is much more important than the
influence of the parents all right
people often say well you know the
mother mother corrects the child and
blah blah blah and so therefore we have
to correct a lot we don't the correct if
the peers were not the greater influence
then the children of immigrants would
end up speaking like their parents which
they don't the children of immigrants
end up speaking like their peers so the
peer is a much bigger influence hi Steve
we follow Ukrainian elections do you
have an informed opinion no I have not
an informed opinion you know this is
Sergey Orla all I can say is I have you
know what can I say I and the Ukrainians
you know learning Ukrainian was I really
enjoyed learning Ukrainian I enjoyed
reading history books in Ukraine II
Ukrainian listening to audiobooks listen
to from ask a radio where they have some
very good podcasts sort of really solid
sensible people but like in every
country starting with the United States
Canada you name it you've got the whole
gamut of people of opinions of crazies
of you name it and Ukraine is no
different but it just seems to me that
throughout history Ukraine has like you
know you had you know Galicia call it
where the Danijela had this princedom
dukedom whatever was then they were
conquered by the Lithuanians who are
more or less tolerant
the polls come in there and they want to
force them to become Roman Catholic
polls and so that created a lot of
bitterness and how men Magnitsky
rebellion he took took a part of Ukraine
off to Russia so and they're kind of
buffeted between the Tatars and the even
the Germans and the Lithuanians and the
poles of the Russians and so they've
kind of had a tough time so here you
have Ukraine now and sort of finally
establishing itself as a equal member of
the European community of nations
alongside Poland Czechoslovakia Republic
and France and Italy and stuff and
they're having their difficulties and of
course it's difficult for Russia to let
go it just like it was difficult for
friends to let Algeria go it's difficult
for Spain to accept the couple with
difficult in Canada for English Canada
to recognize that giving the Kubik
wanted a sense of their own thing now to
squeak by referendums in Quebec you know
which you know we managed to avoid a
separation but it might have happened it
might have had and so there's all kinds
of you know nostalgia what was and stuff
like that and so but in all of this you
know I have no idea and the course of
the corruption in Ukraine such a
fabulously rich country rich agriculture
high-technology very smart people IP and
all this stuff and hard-working you
travel around there and certainly in
western Ukraine your homes are so well
maintained and they build their little
shrines but the roads are terrible
there's corruption there's stuff like
that
I mean my only hope I have no idea about
the candidates my only hope is that that
Ukraine is able to solve its problems
and move forward and I'm looking forward
to going there and I love lists into
Ukrainian just as much as I love
listening to Russia and I won't even get
on the subject of of officially
recognizing Russian because it gets a
call a Ukrainians upset by Russian
culture is also a major part of Ukraine
it's in today's environment of course
with the Russians doing what they're
doing in in Donbass that's not a popular
opinion but so there you have it briefly
on Ukraine now I got a bunch of nastika
[Music]
so how can I prove my speaking fast
nothing happens fast in language okay
but to speak well you have to speak a
lot and you first of all have to build
up your passive vocabulary your
comprehension and then you really have
to speak a lot and then if you do that
your fluency will gradually improve but
everything improves slowly wow they're
very happy when Steve comes to Korea
when i improve my Korean I will be there
oh yeah okay how do I know which words
are important I wouldn't worry about it
so much sometimes the least important
words of the words that you remember the
most important words are ones that you
forget you know if if you don't want the
word like if you're at live if I don't
want the word I don't bother with I
might still save it
I don't deliberately try to remember
anything
all right listening company is not good
any advice listen more and then read
what you listen to how is your Han GE
kanji recognition head ready and Billy
right now are considering you're no
longer learning these languages do you
have to write okay no I don't write
anymore
I haven't written since my I had a pad
to write a test in 1969 I had to
translate newspaper editorials into
Chinese I could write since then I
haven't written if you don't write all
the time you quickly lose the ability to
write but I have no difficulty
recognizing Chinese so I maintain it by
reading and I can write with word
process with it with the computer Brasil
my Rebecca God I know him who says that
speak the language but it's no flow and
is completely wrong because he says you
speak your phone sorry I know my role he
says that a person who says that one is
completely wrong because he said if you
speak your phone what do you think okay
I don't I'd like to hear that from my
row I don't know
exactly when he said but I think the
goal is fluency fluency doesn't mean
perfect you can still make mistakes and
be fluency know when I started German
and Italian from scratch over again with
us email using Luke on Facebook yeah I
mean Luke is a phenomenal polyglot he
works with this translation by a
directional translation I don't have the
patience to do it it might be a very
good method I can to be more of a Zen
you know Thomas you know line of least
resistance so I just believe more in the
sort of gradual exposure okay I wanna
work as a translator good good luck
which culture that you have immerse
yourself and has provided you with the
richest history and culture all all I
mean okay check you know ten million
people but together they have a website
the radio you know HST arrows class has
a series on check history
austro-hungarian Empire blah blah blah
it's all good Arabic Persian Persia like
there's a tremendous culture there
Arabic no there are but if you remember
you said you work for the Canadian
government how did you get into such a
profession but you need to speak another
okay got a bunch of question I try to
get through them all here but the there
was a diplomatic exam so I don't know
what the situation is today but in those
days maybe twenty thousand people write
it and they choose 50 people so any
anything you can do to make yourself
stand out he's gonna help so I wrote my
exam in French even though I was an
Anglophile that I think improved my
chances then they look at so many things
like in those days they wanted to get
people from different parts of the
country nowadays you want to get men and
women they want people with different
backgrounds engineer doctor political
science whatever so it's more of a
lottery than anything else I don't know
how it works today I've been learning
processes beginner everyone's thinking
about
or just three non because okay that's
totally arbitrary Mateos how we divide
up the levels it's quite it's quite
arbitrary Jackie is not biasing okay yes
I see many people improving and I don't
and the advice of both do you think
precision in today's are important of
course they're important but they're not
the most important thing I know people
in Canada who speak with very pronounced
accents I used to have a Swiss banker
guy strongly the Doug did Doug that's
how they speak totally but his use of
words was so good he spoke better than
most native speakers so the focus on
your ability to use words and you can
also work on a pronunciation but it's
not as important as long as people can
understand and the better control you
have of the language overall and the
more listening you do chances are your
pronunciation will improve but I've come
to resent the lack edge a lot okay so if
you resent the language is hard to learn
and this is not an uncommon thing if
you're living somewhere and the locals
like typically at first you arrive
somewhere and it's all new and different
and stuff and after a while the locals
start to rub you the wrong way and so
many things you resent and then you
resent the language maybe either you
move or try to find something in the
local language local culture some
friends something that you would like
it's better if you can find something
there like you don't have to like them
all you don't have to be blind to the
say shortcomings of the locals but you
have to find something positive in my
opinion a grated readers what do you
think of them I mean graded readers are
good because but it depends on the
subject matter personally I'm not that
interested in reading graded fiction I
would be interested in seeing graded
readers on Arabic history or Persian
history or things of that nature
whereas stories I'm not so keen and it's
difficult the graded readers very often
because their stories there's a lot of
vocabulary in there that in fact is not
so relevant so graded nonfiction I would
be very keen on with audio we had that
in China
and it was great I'm not very interested
in Esperanto I'm not against Esperanto
but I'm not motivated to learn it I have
never sat on an airplane as I happened
me when I was flying from from iguazu
falls in Brazil to Rio and I sat beside
the gentleman who turned up a rancher
from Paraguay but who was the Ukrainian
origin we spoke Ukrainian I have never
come across anyone who speaks Esperanto
there is no Esperanto country personally
I'm not motivated but a lot of people
are into Esperanto that's fine it has
the advantage apparently it being easy
to learn so that would be a reason to
teach it in schools so that kids realize
that in fact they can learn a language
but if they're not motivated than that
won't work either I wonder my French
popularity on ebooks on Amazon how they
won't sell it to me ma'am I want to read
ok I mean if find other sources the
problem is that now a lot of those
ebooks are protected so you can import
them but you should be able to find
other booksellers you know I said I
don't know who the other you know and
find the audiobooks for these ebooks I
have been only invited back never you
know kind of I realize that should all
scream oysters your time is spent
reading old lessons well again Edwyn
right now where I am in Arabic and farsi
I'm spending 50% of my time on old
lessons because I'm not good enough to
hit the the new stuff and I've gotta get
out of that but it's difficult and
there's still so much in the old lessons
that I don't want and I struggle with
this maybe I shouldn't be forcing myself
to get better at the old stuff but the
new stuff is too difficult it's that
intermediate level stuff that's missing
his appearance have no I haven't seen
this guy Chilean tbh what do you think
about online tutors that don't make
corrections for you
I don't expect my tutor to make
corrections I won't remember them anyway
I rely on the tutors send me my report
which contains 10 or 15 phrases that I
used incorrectly or the words that she
introduced to me and I studied that but
while we're talking I focus on
communicating I don't think there's much
benefit in correcting on the fly we
don't remember the Corrections anyway
okay I'm gonna have to call it here we
went way over time today okay thank you
and look forward to the next one